let's suppose 2016 and you're back on
the East Coast instead of just blindly
submitting to contest you would try to
create a group of people and and emulate
what you just said yeah we would
definitely just create the work and you
know we'd share the work all of that
kind of stuff I mean these days now you
can put pieces of it you can put pieces
of it online you know what I mean you
can have video proof of what you did
that was amazing you know there's so
many different ways and that's an
excellent way to meet new actors because
we we did a reading out here recently of
one of my screenplays and I did the same
exact thing a theater let us use a let
us use a theater for free and I cooked
and all that kind of stuff and but I
actually went on two actors access or
whatever so that I could cast it with
real actors and they were amazing they
came in they auditioned they did the
whole thing for reading Wow it was
incredible and they were really good
like amazing actors amazing people it
was like a great night and everyone
enjoyed themselves so when you do that
if you do it again people come because
they not even just seen the work again
it's fellowship it's you know meeting
people meeting new talent you know other
writers other producers directors actors
yeah yes cars old cars and little
pockets we never seen any right or the
phone is right here yeah don't look up a
whole different thing when you're
connecting on that other level yeah I
kind of miss the 90s yeah and of course
this is a writer oh my gosh how it's
what better way you know not only do you
get to see your work in the mouths of
real actors doing all kinds of things
what works what doesn't all that but you
have people who are gonna talk to you
about how they felt and this scene made
me feel this way or I thought this way
about that scene and that is just that's
like incredible for you it's like you
know gold
human connections in human connection
and they're really giving you what they
felt or thought
you